for the last nine years thousands of
people have experienced a unique annual
festival celebrating the art of
photography
it's called fotoville a pop-up city of
images featuring a diverse array of work
by photographers
professional and amateur famous and
unknown jamie wax was in brooklyn bridge
park and
st anne's warehouse here in new york for
last year's festival
[Music]
it's september of 2019 and nestled under
the brooklyn bridge is a village
constructed out of shipping containers
inside those containers are worlds of
visual storytelling
[Music]
collectively known as photoville
there's one exhibition i'd love to show
you maybe we could go over here
sure laura romanos is the executive
director of fotoville and is one of the
co-founders
alongside sam barzillai and dave shelley
when we first did this people were
bulking oh we're coming to brooklyn
oh look look at these shipping
containers the two coolest elements of
the entity
started with five shipping containers
and has grown into a major annual
festival featuring work from around the
globe
as well as a traveling gallery known as
the fence
which has brought hundreds of thousands
of images to numerous host cities
how do you manage to operate at this
scale as a non-profit
and offer it for free we have over 150
partners just for photoville
this is a three-quarter of a million
dollar event but you have so many
stakeholders that all have put in
something that
to them it means something those
stakeholders make it possible to
literally
shed light on individual experiences and
perspectives
with an impact that goes beyond what
words can achieve
it's a language and a communication of
way for humans to
experience each other it's also a way to
make history of things that you're
trying to remember
to recreate at the same time what's
changed
in photography the amount of
digital images that are created every
single day
and then as sam says and then are not
destroyed
as they should as some [ __ ] as some
should be certainly
lots of things on my phone it is my
passion but now that it's become a
language we're all using we have to
evolve
in how we're using and sort of maybe use
a little more responsibly and let that
language evolve on its own
as well as it keeps changing fotoville
partners with established photographers
from the new york times
national geographic and others to bring
exposure
access and education to amateur
photographers
like some of these young women who
traveled from louisiana to showcase
their photography
for an enthusiastic new york audience so
this was a new experience for you
yeah especially working with the cameras
and having people travel out
to new orleans to teach us what did you
learn
in this experience i learned that
there's
something that we take for granted so
simple as water that it has a lot of
symbolism
i knew new orleans floods a lot and
using photography like it actually
helped me with
my anxiety with water because i was
spending wellness for katrina so i'm
still nervous like even talking about it
i'm nervous
so this made you face your fear but of
course
all of that was before covet 19 made a
major festival
hard to picture was there a moment where
you said nothing's going to happen this
year
we are never saying never kind of people
or you know looking around going
we should be doing more of these
exhibitions outside and again this is
nothing new for us we've been doing this
for nine years so it wasn't
that we had to change what we were doing
we had to kind of convince
everyone else that this was a good idea
even a pandemic couldn't stop photoville
from returning this year
with more distance and more locations
throughout new york city
we have over 60 exhibitions hundreds of
photographers
over a hundred partners in this so it
definitely takes a village to make this
work
how did it feel for you from the germ of
this idea
to be standing surrounded by
these visual stories that you've helped
curate in times square
we thought it was a dream and we have
this mentality and i hope everyone
should feel this way is that
it never hurts to ask i said look we
aren't really flashy we don't really
have any money
but i have a really great project for
you and elias williams a
new york photographer he went all over
new york city
and interviewed recent graduates and as
we all work our own way through the once
unimaginable changes in our daily lives
romano's
says that photography will tell lasting
stories about this
experience as well it is really
important for us
though to be supporting independent
photojournalists and visual storytellers
to try and raise more money to be able
to pay them to give them more of a
platform
and hard times make for great art when i
think of the young women
from new orleans it was such a big part
of photoville to have
artists who were disenfranchised or
marginalized be able to
come to new york and meet other creative
people
and you've lost that element to it what
what does that make you feel for this
year
that is the one thing that we've missed
that was the whole point of photovoltaic
community coming together in our village
so i'm really hoping that in the future
we'll get back to that whether it's with
containers or whether it's just outdoors
[Music]
it really is about storytellers
and folks being able to tell their own
story
for cbs this morning saturday jamie wax
new york oh i love that that young woman
talked about how it helps her
with her anxiety i mean just think about
what that can do for so many people
think of all the art that's going to
emerge over the next generation just
based on
everything that's happened this year
yeah certainly including that yeah